why is America doing so poorly in speed
skating to us athletes were favourites
to win but neither came close to even
getting a medal and a story in The Wall
Street Journal says a design flaw in
their Under Armour racing suits may be
to blame I'm not sure if that's the case
so I want to bring in Under Armour's
founder Kevin Plank Kevin thank you for
joining me this morning sat down just a
few weeks ago we were very excited about
the Mach 39 tell me about it what's your
reaction to all this well I think
beginning with our mission is to make
athletes just a little bit better and
give them an edge whatever they're
competing in particularly in this case
for our our speed skating athletes on
the ice and so you know we're sitting in
is there's a bit of a head-scratcher
where I think the team isn't performing
as well as any of us hope to and you
know we're sort of at halftime through
through the race and I think everybody
looking at it and saying what
adjustments can be made and look when
you're not performing you look at
everything and it begins with from the
training to the the gear to the skates
to you know the pillows that you slept
on the night before and so it's all very
fair and this is our business and you
know hopes I think that we believe we've
got an incredible product that can you
know help our athletes see it succeed
and win even though this is the first
time you've made this product you
designed it with Lockheed Martin can you
walk me through how it's been beta
tested I mean they didn't just put these
suits on for the first time a few days
ago did they no no we've had the
relationship for since 2011 and I've
been working closely hand-in-hand with
the team and the athletes and if Ted
Morris the executive director at US
speed skating and we've had a great
relationship and so I you know I don't
want this to be perceived as anything
other than I think every sort of just
trying to find out what can we do to
help our athletes win and you know we've
we've tested in on this project in
particular we worked with directly with
Lockheed Martin had everything from
computational fluid dynamic modeling and
Windtunnel testing to get these things
built and so we've built not just one
suit but we've built multiple suits for
the athletes out there so this isn't a
question of it's trying to find I think
the right mix and you know we've got a
full team that's on the ground in Sochi
right now that's making modifications
and adjustments which is completely
typical for what you do at this type of
level of high speed performance
athletics and so you know this is part
of the game and we're making tweaks
right now with our team on the ground
we're gonna put our athlete to the best
position of win it bring home gold I'd
like you to explain that a little more
it's not abnormal for mid Games teams
they're to be adjusting how the uniform
is put together because when I read it
saying well they're adding a flap
they're taking off the off a flap I'm
thinking that's late to the party am I
mistaken well I think some of some of
the things I'm coming out about the
venting in some of the suits and so we
actually made modifications to some of
the original suits we had that had a
vent in the back and I think some of the
questions was is that creating a
parachute effect which none of our
previous testing and when we delivered
the suits in January to the teams to the
athletes and the coaches and the testing
for the six weeks leading up to the
competition
none of that showed up so then there was
a question so we actually have our team
on the ground adjust and take the
vetting out and close the venting and
you know we did that for the women's in
the 1000 and you have the you know to
top like rank people in the world and
they finished one and two and the
finishing seventh and eight and so
you're just again sitting here
scratching your head saying what can we
do to get an advantage so we're still
over there we're making modifications
and adjusting and you know put our
athletes in the best position to win
Kevin there are six events left if in
fact they do decide there is some sort
of problem with the suit they're not
comfortable with the suit and the
players want to change what they're
wearing and maybe what they're wearing
isn't an Under Armour product would you
be okay with that in the hopes that they
come home of the gold well logically we
made three different suits for number
one is the best technology the first
suit that we did with all the
computational fluid dynamic testing we
made the exact same suit with no flow
molding whatsoever on it and then we
also have the the suits that the teams
worked out and used and the World Cup
and the Olympic Trials and so you know
look all of these that's our disposal
we're not going to stand in the way of
our athletes competing and winning and
in finding ways to bring them champions
we remain Patriots first and as we look
at this we want to give our athletes the
best advantage when they're standing at
the starting line and a lot of times in
this case two it starts with just a
belief that they believe that this thing
can help them win and they're gonna win
and to get this in their head that it's
something slowing them down and that's
let's make a change there's two types of
coaching that you can do and number one
is you stick you stick with it and you
find consistency and the other side is
you know when you have some adversity
you shuffle the deck so I don't know if
anybody
got the lock on which one is absolutely
right but you know we stand behind us
speech gating and we're gonna sit here
and root our tails off which is about
what we can do right now Kevin the Dutch
Coates overheard a couple of speedskater
saying they felt that the suits were
slowing them down do you think they
could just be psyching themselves out do
you think maybe they just haven't
trained at the right altitude I don't
you know these are athletes are
world-class athletes that do this all
the time and so you know when you start
getting into you know hearsay and
subjectivity none of that has come back
to us you know we've had a great
partnership with us speed skating and
again our job is making those athletes
believe that when they walk out there
that they've got the best they're the
best advantaged to actually compete and
more importantly win and so you know we
feel like we're doing that and we'll
continue to do that through the the last
five or six events here Nike had a
problem with the suits that they
produced in 2006 so they went back to an
older model so it's safe to say we've
seen this happen before and there's a
lot of tweaking as it relates to speed
skating suits correct we're focused on
on 2014 we're focused on suits on Sochi
and making sure that again they've got
every advantage and so like I said we've
got a full team that's been on the
ground you know in Sochi since before
the games that it's completely setup to
make modifications adjustments you know
fit tweaks and other things that we can
do they have three multiple suits that
they can wear ones that have everything
that is is that we came up with with
Lockheed and our own design team
ionisation team as well as things that
are you know much more basic and a lot
more in line with what they've worn in
the past and so the team and you know us
speed skating can have to make some
decisions there and you know we stand
firmly behind them and whatever they
choose to do Kevin your plan was never
to sell on the heels of this a ton of
speed skating suits but you're under a
lot of pressure to grow internationally
even though your footprint in the US is
extraordinary
it's definitely Rock Nike
internationally it hasn't what do you
think could be the outcome the result of
your international sales push if things
aren't really working out for you here
look this is this is one that we look at
and say it's a great marketing platform
for us to tell our stories about you
know our own competency and our
expertise and making you know the
world's fastest product and so look
look here is that this race is far from
over you know I think everyone should
take a deep breath and let's see how
everything turns out but you know we've
got a big push in global we're gonna
grow and you know I don't I don't see a
real parallel between what's happening
right now and what's happening with
Under Armour to global scene so there's
a lot more to come for both of them and
especially a lot more to come from you a
speech heating cap some people are
saying this could be your Lululemon
moment what do you say to that oh my
gosh come on this is a this is a first
of all this is and this is an honor of a
moment and exactly we don't get you know
we don't get to choose when you get to
lead and so you're always gonna have you
know good days and you'll have days that
you'll face adversity and so I wouldn't
call this adversity and I'd say we're
talking about the US speed skating team
we're talking about them you know having
the ability to to win so look there's
there's still a lot more ice in front of
us so let's let's let the athletes get
out there and see what happens is there
any other Under Armor gear being worn by
Olympic athletes right now who are
winning medals maybe not in speed
skating well we do you we do the
Canadian snowboard team we've got the
skeleton and the bobsled teams are still
out there and you're coming off you know
we've outfitted bobsled the last several
Olympics and you know they brought
Holden home gold the Steve Holcomb you
know in the driving the night train with
the four-man bobsled team so there's a
lot more athletes that'll be out there
competing and you know we're really
excited